(accordion music)
(applause)
[Conan O'Brien] This is Kreuzburg.
It's a section of Berlin,
but like every place else
it's just exploding with life and energy.
Here you've got dreadlocks.
People wearing eye patches.
People with parrots.
Parrots with eye patches.
Parrots with dreadlocks.
That's Berlin.
Good to see you.
It takes him seven days
to get through an airport metal detector.
(audience laughs)
Guten Tag, Guten Tag!
Everybody just sees me
and they want a piece of me.
(audience laughs)
[Fan] Hello, Conan O'Brien?
[Conan] Yes, that right!
Hi!
How are you?
I came all the way up
from Bavaria to see you.
You did?
And I have something for you!
(Conan yells)
(audience laughs)
What was that, that was
scary the way you said it!
Settle down!
I'm quite nervous anyways.
Don't worry.
Haha!
I found an error!
If you think you spotted an
error on our show report it.
Haha, I found an error!
That's from our show, you
really do see the show!
That's so nice.
Last show Friday you said
that the chili stuff the chef ate
was five thousand times
hotter than Tabasco sauce.
The noodles were five
thousand times hotter
than Tabasco sauce.
But Tabasco sauce is 5,000 Scoville
and what he ate had 20,000,000.
5,000 times 5,000 is two
million five hundred thousand.
So you would have, should have said 4,000.
And the article even said so.
But since you don't have the time,
I found a lot more errors, errors.
(audience laughs and cheers)
I made a list with another 50.
Okay. These are all the errors
that you found on my show?
I do watch your show,
but I watch it at 2.6 times the speed.
I found a lot of mistakes.
You found a lot of mistakes on our show?
[Fan] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
[Conan] And you traveled two hours
to give me these mistakes?
[Fan] Yeah. Almost three hours, yeah.
[Conan] Three hours from Bavaria?
[Fan] Yes.
[Conan] And uh...
We Germans, we mean business.
Yeah, you do mean business.
Yes.
You stay right there.
Can you come here for a second?
Yeah.
I want to talk to you about your friend.
(audience laughs)
I'm really worried about him.
Yeah, handwritten so you know-
(Conan exclaims over Fan)
(audience laughs)
It's all good!
No one gets hurt!
All good!
(audience laughs)
Get him medicine, okay?
We'll rejoin him now.
Well, this is fantastic.
(Fan laughs loudly)
Thank you very much.
Listen, it's called Ritalin.
35 milligrams.
(audience laughs)
Very high, it's what they
use on circus elephants.
(Conan pats Fan's shoulder)
(audience laughs)